[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei viertel nach acht ich habe
eine großartige gäste für sie und
deswegen möchte ich auch keine zeit für
den und direkt stark die politikerin und
autorin caroline bosbachs ist auch
vorsitzender jungen wirtschaftsrates und
sind gerade noch bei let's dance getanzt
und ist jetzt fahre hier zu uns im
studio getanzt ich freue mich sehr dass
die nase vor bosbach neben ihr jan
schäfer bild politik chef niemand
erklärt politik und wirtschaft sowie er
sie werden heute einiges lernen das
verspreche ich ihnen dann aus österreich
bei uns heute im studio kolumnist autor
und sie haben auch ihr buch mitgebracht
dürfen sie gerne mal zeigen ich bin
derselbe autor in das ist sein buch
konzerne an die kette das sagt einiges
über die überzeugung herbold männer
schön dass sie da sind last und liest
jana schimpfte sie ist cdu-politikerin
bundestagsabgeordnete
politikwissenschaftlerin es wird hier
heute hochpolitisch und direkt am anfang
möchte ich zu unserem korrespondenten
dem bild vize pforzheimer in kiew
schalten parador das gestern die
exklusive nachricht über steinmeier und
jetzt also steinmeiers ausladungen oder
dass er nicht kommen sollte du kannst
besser erklären als ich wie ist die lage
jetzt wie sieht es aus mit frank walter
steinmeier du hast uns auch eine these
mitgebracht
janina die situation um falk walter
steinmeier ist weiter eskaliert so kann
man es sagen denn heute sind vier
präsidenten angekommen unter anderem der
polnische präsident zusammen mit den
baltischen staatsoberhäuptern und da
wollte frank walter steinmeier
eigentlich mitfahren durfte er aber
nicht offenbar hatte er noch versucht
dann auch die anderen dazu zu bewegen
nicht zu reisen um nicht völlig
brüskiert dazustehen frank walter
steinmeier hat das flugzeug zurück nach
berlin genommen aus polen und in
deutschland ist wieder die übliche moral
debatte entbrannt aber nicht darüber ob
wir möglicherweise fehler gemacht haben
im umgang mit der ukraine ob frank
walter steinmeier fehler gemacht hat
nein nein nein wir deutschen sind ganz
sicher das war böse von selensky das
hätte nicht passieren dürfen das war ein
riesen riesengroßer fehler und wir
beschäftigen uns mal wieder vor allem
mit uns selbst es geht uns wieder nur
darum was ist mit deutschland wir reden
viel zu wenig darüber dass hier täglich
täglich weiter menschen sterben in kiew
wo ich gerade bin ist es momentan ruhig
aber an mario pohl sterben weiterhin
jeden tag menschen ist droht eine riesen
offensive im osten und ich finde es
typisch für deutschland ganz unabhängig
davon dass man sagen kann dass das von
selen ski vielleicht nicht so klug war
ihnen da mehr oder weniger auszuladen so
wie ich das gestern ja auch gesagt hat
aber ganz unabhängig davon beschäftigen
wir uns seit 24 stunden damit
selbstmitleid mit deutschland zu haben
und mitleid mit frank walter steinmeier
zu haben anstatt darüber zu sprechen was
hier die ukraine jetzt dringend braucht
nena und das sind waffen
pauli würde ich dir direkt gerne noch
eine rückfrage stellen unser
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat ja auch
gesagt dass er etwas irritiert darüber
sein dass frank walter steinmeier nicht
in die ukraine reisen sollte wie sieht
es denn jetzt mit seinem besuch aus weil
der stand ja auch noch aus
beziehungsweise die einladung von selen
ski steht ja soweit ich weiß
ja sie lenski wollte dass bundeskanzler
oft hierher kommt denn er sagt scholz
entscheidet über waffen und sanktionen
mit dem musik reden mit frank walter
steinmeier werde ich irgendwann reden
das muss aber jetzt nicht sein das mag
wie gesagt alles taktisch unklug gewesen
sein aber noch einmal der mann und ich
habe ihn ja mehrfach getroffen die in
den vergangenen zwei monaten
der ist dort im tunnel der schläft im
bunker der schläft nur drei bis vier
stunden und der hat eine riesengroße
angst dass die zweite offensive
russlands nämlich im osten sehr viel
erfolgreicher sein könnte als in kiew
dass dort die waffen die man jetzt hat
nicht reicht und deswegen hat er gesagt
moment mal deutschland schickt uns nicht
genügend waffen deutschland macht diese
sanktionen nicht mit warum soll ich
jetzt ausgerechnet denjenigen empfangen
der ja für diese russland politik stehen
noch einmal das ist jetzt meine
interpretation das hat er nicht
öffentlich gesagt hat sich noch gar
nicht dazu geäußert aber das ist das was
die gedanken hier sind in der ukraine
und ich finde wir sollten in deutschland
jetzt ganz schnell aufhören diese moral
und selbstmitleids debatte zu führen
sondern ganz schnell dazu kommen zu
sagen wir räumen wir das jetzt wieder
aus machen wir halt den ersten schritt
das ist doch egal mein gott es geht hier
um einen krieg und es geht um
menschenleben
frosch im für wiese stehen sie dazu zu
dieser moral debatte die provinz hama ja
das ist natürlich wieder typisch deutsch
ich wundere mich dass frank walter
steinmeier überhaupt diese anfrage an
die ukraine gestellt hat dort zuerst
hinzukommen denn gewissen ihm seine
vergangenheit wir wissen er war
kanzleramtsminister wir wissen um sein
verhältnis zu russland das wir zurzeit
aktiv diskutieren in den medien und in
der öffentlichkeit und die fragen sind
noch nicht beantwortet welche rolle er
eigentlich tatsächlich spielt in diesem
ganzen drama das wir zurzeit erleben und
insofern ich finde das kann man sogar
als provokation verstehen dass gar frank
walter steinmeier der erste ist der see
lenski besuchen will nicht kannte lenski
voll verstehen da geht es um alles da
geht es um leben und tod die
interessieren sich nicht dafür ob da
jetzt der bundespräsident kommt oder
nicht nein die wollen den vollen
geholfen werden ja und nicht provoziert
werden und nicht zu irgendetwas
gezwungen werden worauf sie keine lust
haben ich kann das absolut
nachvollziehen ich muss sagen ich kann
das absolut gar nicht nachvollziehen
aber ich mache jetzt gleich auch erst
mal die runde ich finde das mit damit
dass frank walter steinmeier nicht
empfangen wurde oder nicht empfangen
werden sollte gefühle auch ich mich
ausgeladen er ist der repräsentant des
deutschen volkes und ich finde wir
bürger haben doch auch viel es gibt ja
auch viele flüchtlingshelfer in
deutschland sollte er nicht unser
repräsentant fangen werden von silversea
das mag ja sein aber da müssen wir uns
auch mal ein stück weit ehrlich machen
welche rolle spielt in deutschland in
diesem konflikt in der beziehung zu den
zu den russen und was haben wir denn
tatsächlich von eigenen versäumnissen da
auch aufzubringen und worin liegen die
ursachen
da müssen wir uns mal ehrlich machen und
nicht rumjammern gegeben die frage mehr
weiter an den flügel caroline bosbach
hier sehen sie das denn ich kann beiden
aussagen was abgewinnen ich verstehe
auch beides habe natürlich für alle hier
auch gedanken dazu gemacht gerade in den
letzten 24 stunden es war schon hart das
hat natürlich hier getroffen also das
was du jetzt irgendwas sagt dass man
sich als deutscher das kann ich nicht
bestätigen ich fühle mich da persönlich
überhaupt nicht tangieren es ist
tatsächlich eher so dass natürlich
drängt die frage auf wem hilft das wem
hilft ist in dieser situation grad der
ukraine ist die allerletzte die das grad
gebrauchen können dass man sagt man ja
immer nett ihn jetzt aus auf der anderen
seite und das finde ich eigentlich das
wichtige signal zeigt das ja irgendwo
auch wie verzweifelt die ukraine auf
unsere zögerlichkeit reagiert auf das
wir dass wir einfach nicht voran machen
das ist das signal was ich daraus lesen
das finde ich ein absolut richtiges und
wichtiges argument und wir sehen das ja
gerade auch am heutigen tag wenn es um
die frage geht wie wie tief sind
eigentlich spd-politiker und frank
walter steinmeier war bis vor ein paar
jahren bevor dann bundespräsident war
klassisch spd politiker wie tief ist
eigentlich diese partei verstrickt in
beziehungen zum kreml und so putin und
wer sich heute auch noch mal bilder
anschaut beispielsweise von manuela
schwesig der ministerpräsidentin von
mecklenburg vorpommern und das in bezug
setzt zum thema noch zum 2 der wird
feststellen dass es vielen
spd-politikern bei nordstream zwei rein
um interessen gehen das kreml und
angeblich auch westeuropäischen
interessen das thema osteuropa spielte
auch in aussagen von manuela schwesig
nie eine rolle und wir wissen aber dass
gerade die osteuropäischen länder seit
jahren von nord stream zwei wannen und
gewarnt haben und jetzt sehen wir was
passiert ist und da kann ich die
reaktion von seelen ski durchaus
verstehen in der ukraine hat man den
eindruck diese pipeline hat massiv dazu
beigetragen
dass man russland nicht als den die das
land gesehen hat was es ist nämlich als
ein gefährliches land sondern dass man
immer versucht hat alles was an signalen
an schlechten signalen aus dem kreml kam
zu übertünchen und plötzlich gibt es
einen angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
und man gibt deutschland in gewisser
weise die mit schulden zumindest kann
man das bei der kungelei die wir gesehen
haben zwischen sozialdemokraten und dem
kreml aus den vergangenen jahren
verstehen wann bei der steiner hat sich
entschuldigt auch er hat ja auch sein
verhalten aus den letzten jahren etwas
revidiert aber wir kommen einmal hier zu
unserem österreichischen bürger am tisch
wie sehen sie das wie nehmen sie das
wahr ich meine es gab ja auch ein
staatsbesuch aus österreich ja auch
nicht so wahnsinnig rühmlich also wenn
ich jetzt höre dass frank walter
steinmeier versucht wird andere menschen
andere amtsträger ringen davon
abzuhalten dorthin zu fahren das ist
schon mal noch eine charakterfrage über
die deportiert werden sollte aber
grundsätzlich denke ich mir man muss
jetzt schon einen gewissen pragmatismus
auch in der perspektive von salewski
verstehen ich glaube toleranz damals
auch angedeutet es geht jetzt nicht um
irgendeine repräsentations besucher ist
einfach nicht die zeit dafür ich man das
sterben das sterben menschen wenige
kilometer von hier entfernt und
verbraucht der entscheidungsträger dort
der braucht jetzt quasi nicht in den
star und schöne bilder zu machen
irgendwie ein
zeichen der solidarität zu zeigen
sondern braucht es ganz konkrete hilfen
er braucht waffenlieferungen und er
braucht das maßnahmen auch innerhalb der
europäischen union getroffen werden und
das ist die gleiche kritik die man auch
an karl hammer dem österreichischen
bundeskanzler gemacht hat nämlich sich
die frage zu stellen wer derweil die
kritik dass er direkt nach moskau weiter
geflogen aber die gleiche thematik was
bringt das wenn ein österreichischer
bundeskanzler sich quasi in moskau
inszeniert das muss doch klar sein dass
er instrumentalisiert wird das muss doch
klar sein dass nur der agenda von putin
hielt und es ist gleichzeitig meine frau
gegenüber der ukraine ist und wenn wir
jetzt sehen dass frank walter steinmeier
quasi sich das vorrecht nehmen wollte
starts überhaupt dorthin gesucht waren
daneben die schönen bilder zu machen
während gleichzeitig olaf scholz um die
deutsche regierung sich davor drückt
echte solidarität zu zeigen und zwar so
wie selensky und zu kriegen ist auch
einfordert dann ist das schon etwas was
man auch entsprechend bewerten muss hier
würde ich gerne einmal ronzheimer
nochmal in die leitung holen dass gerade
die frage aufgekommen ob staatsbesuch
überhaupt etwas bringen wie würdest du
das einschätzen boris johnson war zum
beispiel auch in kiew
ich glaube schon dass staatsbesuch etwas
bringen und wir haben ja gesehen boris
johnson sind hier große sympathien
entgegen gestoßen aber nicht weil er
sonst sondern weil großbritannien von
anfang an massiv waffen in die ukraine
gebracht hat und das sind waffen die
diese stadt davor bewahrt haben
eingenommen zu werden dass ich ihn noch
sitze zum beispiel und die fliehen
musste oder erschossen wurde oder
festgenommen wurde von russischen
soldaten um es jetzt mal ganz hart zu
personalisieren liegt auch an den waffen
die aus großbritannien und aus den usa
hier nach kiew geliefert wurden denn das
tier gehalten wurde als statt bislang
zumindest und in den nächsten wochen
monaten wird das so sein eventuell gibt
es einen weiteren angriff geben aber
damit hat ja niemand gerechnet also die
geheimdienstler wir alle gesagt in 72
stunden fällt diese stadt und so weiter
und so fort und woran lag das weil
deutschland zum beispiel vor dem krieg
immer gesagt hat nein waffen liefern
wenn ich dass es dann vor großen
provokationen gegen putin
dann fängt er den krieg an als er dann
den krieg angefangen habe man allen
ernstes politiker teilweise gesagt naja
jetzt waffen liefern das würde nur für
eine verlängerung des krieges führen
weil das würde dann ja bedeuten dass die
ukraine die hätten ja trotzdem keine
chance gegen die gegen die russische
armee und ähnlich weit jetzt weiter
argumentiert in richtung osten wo jetzt
wieder gesagt wird ja aber im osten
haben die russische armee ja so viel
mehr kräfte und dann gewinnen die also
man muss auch einmal verstehen warum
hier so viele so wütend sind noch einmal
ich verstehe dass man sagt das war jetzt
vielleicht unklug das war taktisch
vielleicht nicht so klug aber man darf
nicht vergessen wie sehr hier bestimmte
deutsche position und insbesondere
frankfurter stein mehr auf unverständnis
gestoßen haben muss eine korrektur
machen zur debatte steinmeier hat sich
offenbar nicht alleine selbst eingeladen
sondern es soll die idee von herrn duda
dem polnischen präsidenten gewesen sein
dass er dort mit den vier zusammen gehör
kommt das soll die initiative gewesen
sein um so
brüskierte ist der bundespräsident ich
glaube eine solche klatsche hat ein
deutsches staatsoberhaupt in den letzten
jahrzehnten noch nirgendwo kassiert ich
glaube ein besseres schlusswort zu
deiner these paar kann es heute nicht
geben es weiter gut auf dich auf und wir
hören uns morgen abend wieder wie jeden
abend bei film nach acht dankeschön und
damit gehen wir direkt weiter als zu
ihnen herborn männer und sie haben ja
die reichen müssen zahlen ist ihre these
ich bin sehr gespannt wie wir das so
finden ja also im grunde kann nicht dort
anschließen wo paul zimmer aufgehört es
geht darum wir leben jetzt gerade die
ukraine sind land das in trümmern liegt
nun schätzt ungefähr 750 milliarden euro
betragen die materiellen schäden die das
menschliche leid kann man sowieso nicht
aufwiegen und die frage stellt sich
nicht nur wer zahlt den wiederaufbau der
ukraine wenn es hoffentlich irgendwann
mal etwas zum aufbauen gibt sondern auch
wer trägt auch die kosten der versorgung
die wir hier haben in europa wir leisten
gerade sehr sehr großes vor allem polen
deutschland österreich und so weiter und
da ist meine these dass diejenigen die
sich in den letzten 20 jahren unter
putins regime wirklich bereichert haben
auch am russischen volk aber auch an der
welt nämlich die oligarchen die vor
allem in deutschland in österreich in
frankreich und großbritannien groß für
ihr sitzt immer angehäuft haben die 100
milliarden an besitztümern dort
gebunkert haben auch zur kasse gebeten
werden und gleichzeitig nämlich nicht
nur die russischen oligarchen sondern
auch die deutschen und österreichischen
oligarchen unter anführungszeichen also
diejenigen die jetzt in der krise
profitieren die jetzt in der krise um
den letzten monaten aber auch in den
letzten jahren ihr vermögen massiv
steigern konnten auch die sollten zur
kasse gebeten werden wenn wir sehen dass
jetzt die lebensmittelpreise steigen die
gaspreise steigen und so weiter
ich glaube sie sind schwanger punkte in
die da machen und einer über den wir
auch durchaus wirklich intensiv und
ernsthaft diskutieren sollten ich finde
bei dem punkt bemerkenswert wenn wir
haben einmal anschauen wie viel vermögen
denn eigentlich von oligarchen in den
vergangenen wochen eingefroren ist und
dass so ein bisschen europäisch
beleuchten dann stellen wir in dem fall
auch leider wieder fest dass offenbar
wie in deutschland so ein bisschen
einmal mehr auf die bremse treten das
sind so rund 100 millionen euro im
volumen was bisher an vermögen
eingefroren wurde bislang beispielsweise
aus belgien da ist es über eine
milliarde schon auch in italien rund
eine milliarde an vermögen von
oligarchen jetzt kann man sagen italien
ist die mafia bekämpfung quasi
staatsräson das heißt da ist man viel
besser ausgerüstet das kann sein aber es
zeigt sich einmal mehr ich glaube ich ja
deutschland gewaltigen nachholbedarf was
dieses thema angeht und am ende werden
sie die kern frage auf wer bezahlt und
ich glaube dass wir das zum einen bei
den oligarchen abladen sollten aber auch
nicht ganz vergessen sollten das auch
der russische staat am ende für den
wiederaufbau mitbezahlen muss also ich
denke wir sollten da ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein einfach zu sagen die
reichen per se sollen jetzt alles für
alles bezahlen und für alles aufkommen
deutschland ist und bleibt ein
rechtsstaat er und enteignungen gibt es
in deutschland nicht ja außer unter ganz
bestimmten voraussetzungen so und jetzt
zu sagen wir nehmen anderen menschen das
vermögen weg und und schichten das quasi
um damit nehmen wir uns eine menge damit
nehmen wir uns eine menge von unseren
prinzipien von unseren rechtsstaatlichen
prinzipien und mir ist es persönlich
wichtig dass das erhalten bleibt wir
konfiszieren das vermögen ja wir nehmen
es praktisch zur seite wir machen es
nicht mehr verfügbar aber jetzt einfach
zu sagen damit lösen wir die krise das
ist eben nicht die lösung und ich habe
in der tat auch sorge dass das wieder
mal eine blaupause für andere dinge sein
kann dass der staat sich willkürlich
dann auch wiederum bei anderen menschen
bedient die hart für ihr geld gearbeitet
haben oder dies geerbt haben wir auch
immer das ist gut das ist richtig das
darf auch sein und deswegen warne ich
vor solchen populistischen vorschlägen
für die große vielleicht kurz ist
sozusagen nur weil das natürlich ist
eine blaupause ist klar natürlich sollen
wir nicht beim russischen oder gar haben
sie wenn ich meine wirklich jetzt in
berlin in berlin gibt es glaube ich ein
recht erfolgreiches volksbegehren
deutsche wohnen der eignung es geht
darum quasi leistbar zu machen und ich
denke mir natürlich müssen wir und das
ist kristallisationspunkt in dieser
krise quasi das wir sehen dass auf der
einen seite multimilliardäre besitz in
schuss bringen während gleichzeitig
menschen hungern und leiden aber das
gleiche thema haben wir in deutschland
ich finde das deswegen so wie ich diese
grundsatzdebatte führen übrigens nicht
abseits des rechtsstaats weil letztlich
ist der rechtsstaat das was wir als die
in der demokratie in der gemeinheiten
würden sie enteignet
ich finde es obszön dass es menschen
gibt wie zb klaus michael kühne der in
der krise vor sein vermögen von 13
milliarden auf 34 milliarden sein
persönliches vermögen steigern können
aber jetzt jetzt für massig zu gewissen
dingen anders als ist klar wenn wir bei
oligarchen über unrechtmäßig erworbenen
wohlstand reden dann ist das das eine
und wenn wir über ganz legal erworbenen
wohlstand reden dann ist das das andere
was haben sie denn dagegen wenn jemand
hart arbeitet wenn jemand arbeitsplätze
schafft wenn jemand verantwortung für
hundert vielleicht tausend vielleicht 20
vielleicht sogar 100.000 mitarbeiter hat
und dafür am ende gerade steht wenn es
schiefgeht aber dafür natürlich auch
belohnt wird wenn es gut läuft wenn er
sich einsetzt genau ich sagen da habe
ich mich ja nichts dagegen zu sagen
überhaupt nichts dagegen zu sagen
natürlich also
erst mal ich finde es seltsam dass die
grüne gruppe kurzarbeit beantworten
einen krise aber in der anderen
situation wo die milliarden profite
sprudeln nicht zu einer stadt zurück
zahlt das für mich seltsam ich finde es
seltsam dass arbeitnehmerrechte mit
füßen getreten werden ein europaweiter
betriebsrat immer noch verhindert wird
in diesem unternehmen einen aber
freilich in deutschland der betreiber
aus indes sind ja jetzt unter jetzt
mischen sie aber leider ganz kanada 7 1
sie vermischen dass man kann über die
frage reden wenn jemand staatshilfen
bekommt muss sie zurückzahlen das hat ja
nichts mit enteignung zu tun das sind ja
völlig unterschiedliche dinge die selbst
aktiv sie haben selten aber lassen sie
uns einmal in die vergangenheit gehen
das noch gar nicht so lange her ich
erinnere mich selbst daran weil ich noch
ein junger mensch war und immer wieder
das vergnügen hatte in die ddr fahren zu
dürfen ein ein land in dem es in dem es
so gut wie kein privateigentum nur
staatseigentum gab und wenn ich das so
richtig noch in erinnerung habe dann
hatte ich immer den eindruck ob ich mir
die häuser angeschaut habe die autos
auch beim thema umwelt das irgendwie die
bundesrepublik als ein system das auch
eigenkapital auch viel zugelassen hat
oder privateigentum irgendwie in vielen
dingen der ddr voraus war beim thema
sauberkeit beim thema das können wir die
gleichen jetzt mit aber klar aber sie
können doch nicht die haftungsübernahme
die wir unter den solidarbeitrag von
superreichen verlangen damit vergleichen
mit dem was in der ddr war ich meine das
war die
angesprochene innerhalb von fans über
namen kann sich steuerung geworden eines
immobilienkonzern habe ich mir gerade
selbst gesagt habe gesagt dass in berlin
jetzt gerade passiert ist uns
offensichtlich eine mehrheit in der
bevölkerung gab also ich weiß nicht ob
sich die gegen die interessen der
bevölkerung sprechen aber ich sage ihnen
das was hier gerade passiert und das was
mich ärgert ich bin ja hier durch berlin
zum ersten mal hier und ich habe mich im
vorfeld ein bisschen informiert zahlen
und statistiken aus berlin und ich habe
festgestellt dass 27 prozent aller in
berlin lebenden kinder und kränze
aufwächst und gleichzeitig eine legale
ein deutscher oligarch seinen gewinn
innerhalb von einem jahr um 20
milliarden euro gesteigert das ist doch
krank wie das sitzen und sagen wenn wir
jetzt über die besteuerung von
superreichen reden da sind ja gleich
jemand ein milliardenschwerer sie haben
schon einen eignung gesprochen und das
muss man dann grundsätzlich machen den
bezug
haben
für die diskussion ist eine blaupause
für die diskussion ab welchen vermögen
greift der staat ein und ich kann meinen
lage noch mehr als eine milliarde ich
bin da ich bin tatsächlich der meinung
diese diskussion haben wir auch in
schweden die haben in österreich genauso
dass jemand ein milliardenvermögen hat
daraufhin beschlossen mit was macht er
mit dem iran nur uns inwieweit ist das
so ein bisschen mit dem panama papers
wieder was die leute damit machen sie
weiß ob ein milliardär hopp ein
milliardär das geld in seine firma
stecken oder für eine milliarde
champagnerflaschen kauft das ist am ende
wurst man nein das ist ja nicht noch
natürlich nachher gibt das geld aus
ergibt denjenigen die in der champagner
firma arbeiten einen sicheren job das
bein abgenommen sloboda wir sehen sie
das denn vermögen
[Gelächter]
meiner meinung nach ist es absolut nicht
obszön dass aber glaube ich jetzt gar
nicht so da springe ich glaube wir sind
alle daran eigentlich dass wir uns in
deutschland auch in österreich massiv
unterscheiden möchte und es auch tun von
anderen ländern nicht auf dasselbe
rechtsstaat niveau absenken wie zum
beispiel die totalitäre regime da können
glaube ich allen punkten da machen so
dann aber auch die rolle deutschlands in
österreich wenn wir darüber sprechen wie
wir mit solchen oligarchen umgehen ich
denke das geht nur im internationalen
rahmen schweiz monaco großbritannien ich
glaube die haben deutlich größere
probleme ich glaube mit denen sollte man
sprechen wenn wir sagen wir wollen die
tradition sprechen
die yachten der oligarchischen liegen in
der regel nicht in bremerhaven oder in
rostock das heißt im internationalen
verbund sich gedanken zu machen wie man
aus was reagieren könnte wäre
wahrscheinlich dass genau das richtige
ganz unabhängig davon müsse natürlich
diejenigen belangt werden die zunahme
sind ich denke auch da sind wir uns
einig dass dieses vermögen gesperrt
werden muss völlig unabhängig davon was
das für konsequenzen hätte wir wollen
dieses system natürlich in keiner art
und weise darin unterstützen noch eine
ergänzung zur frau bosbach gehe ich mit
aber der reflex der hinter solchen
forderungen steht ist ja immer der zu
glauben man kann damit krisen lösen man
bedient sich einfach bei anderen
menschen und kann damit krisen lösen
löcherstopfen schulden senken was auch
immer aber das ist ja nicht der fall wir
haben es gesehen am ende für uns solche
instrumente dann auch zu einem ab
wirtschaften eines staates und zu dem
was ich selbst als kind erlebt habe aber
jetzt mal kurz bleiben wir im punkt es
geht immer ums geld okay es geht da wie
dort immer ums geld und zu sagen wir
können keine probleme lösen indem wir
das geld von denen die zu viel davon
haben dorthin geben wo es zu wenige die
der staat ist ein guter unternehmer die
frage muss ich ihnen sagen der staat
habe die aufgabe staat ist nicht
unternehmerisch zu agieren die aufgabe
des staates ist das gemeinwohl zu
fördern und die ausgabe startet muss
sein dafür zu sorgen dass ist
ausbalanciert
wenn wir erleben eine satz noch dazu
wenn wir erleben dass in den krisen ob
corona krise oder ukraine krise manche
menschen immer reicher werden während
ganz viele menschen sich ihre wohnung
nicht mehr leisten können jetzt nicht
mehr leisten können dann läuft und dann
zu sagen das werden keine probleme mit
mit der umverteilung von geld gelöst ist
einfach unsinn das stimmt mich natürlich
werden probleme mit umverteilung gelöst
aber es heißt ja nicht dass wir den
krieg auch beenden und gesagt ich habe
auch nicht gesagt dass dadurch dass wir
die russischen oligarchen in deutschland
in österreich und so weiter enteignung
der krieg gelöst wird aber eines müssen
wir schon erkennen dass leute wie
abmahnungen die jets am
verhandlungstisch sitzen als milliardär
hat nur einen einzigen grund weil sie
angst um ihr geld haben und ich glaube
dass wir gut in wird gestützt von einer
elite von menschen den letzten 20 jahre
aufgebaut hat und die haben wahnsinnig
viel geld und sie treffen wir am
stärksten in den venen das geld nehmen
aber es gibt glaube ich da wirklich
unterschiede zwischen einem ehrbaren
kaufmann und jemanden der seinen
milliarden familie avisiert eingangs
auch sagten auf unehrliche art und weise
bekommen hat so durchgang tun das ist ja
schon ein unterschied wie eine herrliche
kaufmann bitte der ist der ehrliche
kaufmann der betriebsrats gründungen in
seinem betrieb verhindert diejenige der
auf kinderarbeit seine produkte stützt
das ist ja ehrlich
wir haben die deutschen ist angesagt ist
gut zum beschluss sondern erst jetzt auf
die idee dahinter ist dass die und was
man unterschied das zu ihnen ich würde
erstmal sagen ein unternehmer der
anfängt zu arbeiten ist per se erst mal
ein guter mensch da sehen sie
wahrscheinlich anders sie unterstelle
mein unternehmen dahin war ich bin sehr
unternehmer dann ist ja wunderbar
verlassen genau und dann kann man noch
immer darüber reden ob es dass es
unternehmer gibt die möglicherweise
nicht so agieren wie sie das gut finden
oder wir das alle gut finden das
bedeutet aber noch nicht dass sie jedem
unternehmer sei auch nie gesagt man weiß
nicht was wir reden also ich rede von
milliardären genau nicht sagen lassen
wir in korea ein vermögen aufgerufen
doch das kann ein mandat doch dann schon
sicher dann sehen wir ein verbrechen
chance sich die liste militär anschauen
und nach vorne und so klatten an woher
kommt denn im moment noch einmal war
steffen ein teil meiner persönlichkeit
ist es familien da müssen wir schon aus
reformieren ich habe gesagt schauen
großen
familie steckt dahinter
aber wissen sie jetzt mit 14 habe nicht
genug getan aber vorbei gegangen jetzt
schaut bitte auf das ist so peinlich
es geht es geht darum wer hat sein
vermögen auf ausbreitung in der nächsten
zeit gegründet sie haben aber jetzt okay
doch aufpassen müssen da aufpassen was
wir sagen und was sie vereint sagen sie
wollen eine grenze bei einer milliarde
einführen und stellen sich jedenfalls
unter generalverdacht nicht ich hab
gesagt sie haben mich gefragt wer
besser kennen zu müssen haben wir zu
reden wir drüber ja genau finden und
mehr als eine milliarde nicht gesagt
jeder über eine milliarde geeignet oder
einen kleinen hat sein vermögen mit
verbrechen gemacht war noch ihre worte
natürlich wir sehen ja
ich würde sagen familie haupt von
tengelmann zum beispiel würde ich ganz
klar sagen es definitiv und ehrbare
kaufleute ja ok ich hab' ich mir gerne
an schon übernächstes in welchen
ursachen übrigens noch ein paar andere
recherchieren sehr gut das ist ein
großes versprechen alle milliardäre
werden recherchiert von herrn barmenia
und wir kommen weiter zu der these jetzt
von fröschen das mache ich sehr gerne
die bundesfamilienministerin eine
spiegel ist am montag zurückgetreten
nach langer hitziger diskussion in
diesem land wir haben alle erfahren von
den chat verläufen in denen deutlich
wurde dass es ihr mehr um ihr
öffentliches ansehen als um das helfen
der dortigen opfer geht wir haben
erfahren dass sie vier wochen im urlaub
war und davon nichts gesagt hat sie hat
auch die unwahrheit gesagt dass sie
angeblich an kabinettssitzungen in
dieser zeit teilgenommen das hat sie
nicht getan in diesem zusammenhang
entstand die debatte darüber ob
politiker politikerinnen in
spitzenfunktionen familie und beruf
tatsächlich vereinbaren können wir haben
erfahren dass frau spiegel in einer sehr
schwierigen familiären situation sich
leider befindet vier kindern mit einem
ehemann der auch 2009 10 einen
schlaganfall hatte alles nicht sehr
leicht wir können das alle
nachvollziehen aber die frage steht im
raum ist jetzt das system politik daran
schuld dass frau spiegel lügen musste
dass frau spiegel sich in einer
bundesweiten notsituation in den urlaub
gegeben hat ich sage nein das system ist
nicht schuld jemand der zwei ministerien
leitet und sich dazu bereit erklärt
jemand der in dieser zeit die
spitzenkandidatur im landtagswahlkampf
übernimmt und dann noch in den bund
wechselt um dort bundesministerin zu
werden der hat sich viele viele fragen
zu stellen gehabt und sich für die
politik entschieden und wir müssen
endlich mal ehrlich sein und den leuten
auch sagen gerade auch die jungen frauen
in diesem land sagen dass man im leben
wirklich nicht alles haben kann man muss
sich manchmal entscheiden möchte ich
mehr rücksicht auf meine familie nehmen
oder ist mir mein beruf wichtiger und
wenn ich mich entscheide in die politik
zu gehen und dort ein spitzenamt ausüben
oder sogar mehrere dann brauche ich
natürlich zu hause jemanden der mir
rückhalt gibt ja der mir hilft er sich
um die kinder kümmert ich finde da ist
ein bisschen mehr ehrlichkeit angebracht
dass diese debatte auch so zu führen
nicht immer so zu tun als wenn im leben
alles möglich ist als wenn wir fünf
kinder haben können wir gleich balance
haben sich einen tollen mann und auch
noch eine karriere ich glaube das ist
märchen und das wird nicht funktionieren
was schimpfe ich glaube wir sind uns in
einem punkt er komplett einig dass weder
das system schuld ist und dazu kommt
auch ist es ganz bestimmt nicht ihre
familiäre situation zu hause gewesen
sondern schlicht und ergreifend ihr
katastrophales krisenmanagement
damit einhergehend auch die art und
weise der kommunikation ich glaube diese
legendäre pressekonferenz sonst noch
einen guten erinnerungen zumindestens
der die sie gesehen hat wird sie so
schnell nicht vergessen
dazu kommt das ja auch erst nach
deutlich um druck aus den eigenen reihen
von den kabinettskollegen von der
parteispitze erst mal aufgewacht ist und
gesagt hat so wir ziehen sie jetzt mal
aus der schusslinie heraus dass es gibt
keinen mehr dann was ich sag mal ich
komme ja auch aus einem entsprechenden
haushalte haben vater und er war 23
jahre lang unter den finals wolfgang
bosbach cdu politiker
der kanzler der herzen übrigens wenn er
da ist er das heißt ich kann zu dieser
debatte tatsächlich irgendwas beitrag
nicht nur weil ich selber im politischen
milieu tätig bin und auch diverse
ehrenämter habe die mich oftmals bis in
die späten abend vor allem auch nachts
stunden beschäftigen wir sind
schwieriges thema aber
es ist kein nine to five job und in
diesem fall muss zu wissen das land
steht vor der person das ist doch völlig
klar wenn du dich um ein solches amt
auch bewirbst und das ist auch wichtig
nach außen zu kommunizieren da kannst du
die schuld nicht abnehmen kannst du
weder am system in die schuhe schieben
noch der familie ist doch dass das dass
das grund des absolute basis wissen aber
jetzt mal so rein von dieser
ministeriale weg aus eigener erfahrung
dass ist auch ein stück weit weiß ich
gerne ganzen würde was wir zur debatte
einfach hinzufügen müssen grad bei uns
in der union wir haben wenig wir haben
junge frauen die sehr weit nach oben
wollen die auch richtig kämpfen wir sind
tatsächlich weniger bekannt die es
schaffen die ganzen kinder zu bekommen
diese möchten und trotzdem weiter vorne
zu kommen woran liegt das ich habe mir
sagen ich bin schon der meinung dass die
ein oder andere strukturelle reform oder
das ein oder andere entgegenkommen nötig
wäre ich rede hier nicht von umwälzungen
oder von absolut reform und stur
umwälzenden prozessen es ist so und das
werden auch die anderen kollegen
bestätigen auch parteiübergreifend
sitzungen bis in die abendstunden sind
lagen sie sind vermögend es muss alles
in präsenz dort führen es kann nicht
digital stattfinden und es ist auch in
ihrer partei so wenn du nicht über 7
oder zwölf jahre hinweg jeden dienstag
zum stammtisch kommst und da wirklich
durchhält und aus holz das sind auch
keine entschuldigungen zugelassen so
wird das nicht es ist verdammt schwierig
ich habe für mich schon persönlich den
anspruch dass ich das alles unter einen
hut bekommen möchte kann aber auch
sowohl von meinem vater also wirklich
aus allererster ebene was ich zu hause
erlebt habe all die jahre und auch von
dem was ich jetzt gerade erlebe da ein
ganz großes
thema könnte man da los treten aber
diskutieren was benötigen würde um auch
gerade für junge frauen diese ganze
szenen diesen ganzen job attraktiver zu
machen finde ich muss darüber reden
platz zwei ist ein total wichtiger punkt
hierbei das thema vereinbarkeit von
familie und beruf nicht nur
politiker betrifft sondern aus eigener
erfahrung kann ich sagen auch journalist
aber da gibt es sicherlich noch ganz
ganz viele andere berufe die genau das
die gleiche herausforderung mit sich
bringen für männer und für frauen ist ja
nicht nur so dass frauen mütter sind
sondern männer können ja auch väter sein
und darüber wird in der politik ja auch
sehr selten gesprochen ich glaube wir
sehen aber auch und sie haben das ja
auch gerade gesagt bei frau spiegel war
möglicherweise dieses amt des
bundesministers oder der
bundesministerin einfachen amt was
vielleicht auch einfach ein ticken zu
groß war es gibt ja ämter wie füllt man
einfach aus weil man auch dafür brennt
und warte bei frau spiegel ich nicht den
eindruck dass das so richtig der fall
war und was ich eigentlich eigentlich
muss ich sagen bedauerlich fand an dem
ganzen auftritt sie hat ja ein
persönliches schicksal das tragisch ist
schicksal gegenübergestellt die
mindestens genauso tragisch sind oder
waren und kerstin der flutkatastrophe
diejenigen nämlich die angehörige oder
freunde verloren haben und auch noch ihr
hab und gut da muss man sagen geht es ja
frau spiegel fast noch gut dagegen dass
ich das irgendwie jetzt schönreden will
aber die situation war sicherlich in
ihrer familie eine andere als sie viele
viele familien im flutgebiet erlebt
haben und auch glaube ich da hat sie
einfach absolut die falschen worte
gefunden an dem abend nur wenn wir bin
ich das vielleicht noch kurz ein werfen
darf wenn wir frauen wirklich helfen
wollen wenn wir frauen in die lage
versetzen wollen im karriere zu machen
eine führungsaufgaben zu übernehmen dann
müssen wir auch über die konsequenzen
reden die das mit sich bringt das ist
eben nicht nur ein teich und das ist
auch kein spaziergang das ist auch
ellbogen ja und das ist auch austeilen
können und das finde ich findet in der
deutschen debatte überhaupt nicht statt
wir von seiten der politik also gerieren
immer das ist alles gar kein problem wir
brauchen nur eine frauenquote und schon
ist das problem gelöst die aber das ist
ja nicht der fall das ist ja nicht der
fall frauen die war da was vorhaben
brauchen so viel unterstützung brauchen
so viele ratschläge brauchen mentoren
brauchen menschen die ihnen auch mal ein
bisschen sagen dass soja und das findet
gar nicht statt und es irgendwann ist es
eine sehr unehrliche debatte die wir
brauchen das nicht auch männer also ich
habe mittlerweile auch bei ich meine die
männer wollen ja vielleicht dann auch zu
hause bleiben wir sprechen über
frauenquoten und besonders europa
mentoren für frauen aber ist es nicht
auch so dass vielleicht für alle schön
wäre wenn sich das etwas ändert im
politbetrieb naja so meine beobachtungen
ist die dass männer einfach mal anders
sind frauen und männer sind
unterschiedlich und die ticken anders
und die vernetzten sich anders und die
männer vernetzen sich sehr sehr früh wir
haben in deutschland sehr lebendige
strukturen mit netzwerken mit bünden ja
die schon in studentenzeiten gegründet
werden und da unterstützt man sich eben
zum beispiel auch ein leben lang und die
ticken auch die stillen zusammen fußball
die machen so gemeinsam mit dinge die
ihnen spaß machen ja ich weiß nicht ob
wir frauen das so machen ich glaube
weniger ja und das ist ein kernproblem
oder dass
der debatte die total wichtig ist die
ist so direkt angeschlossen an den
rücktritt von einem spiegel mutter mit
vier kindern dass es
das ist ein großer job den sie allein zu
hause hat mit ihrem mann zusammen und
dann noch einen job aber ich glaube
lasst uns das doch einmal reduzieren auf
das auf das faktum und da muss man
einfach sagen das hat man auch in der
pressekonferenz gesehen dieser job war
für eine spiegel ob sie kinder hätte
gehabt hat oder nicht ob sie verheiratet
ist oder wie auch immer der job war zu
groß und jetzt wird gleich eine familien
debatte draußen gemacht also das finde
ich ein bisschen unehrlich lasst uns
doch festhalten es gibt jobs für die
sind einige menschen total geeignet und
für andere sind sie nicht geeignet und
wir müssen aber feststellen für anne
spiegel war dieser job einfach zu groß
er bei mir leben kam mit dem kopf
geschüttelt werden sie unsere debatte
zugehört habe ich mir gedacht habe es
gar nicht sein dass wir in deutschland
im jahr 2022 liebe noch auf dem niveau
sind männer und frauen sind heute
unterschiedlichem ein schuldiger es kann
ja wohl nicht wahr sein oder also das
erwarte ich mir überhaupt nicht und das
was sie gerade ansprechendes vollkommen
richtig ich glaube wir haben hier zwei
verschiedene ebenen von einem ganz
wichtigen thema das eine thema zu dem
ich mich äußern möchte weil ich die
hintergründe nicht genug kenne ist ist
die frau spiegel icon gewesen oder nicht
irrelevant viel wichtiger ist eigentlich
die frage unter die familien debatte die
sie so bezeichnen weil das ist wirklich
ein grundsatz thema und ich glaube da
steckt schon auch da drinnen und das
kann man nicht reduzieren auf männer und
frauen sind halt unterschiedlich oder
männer tun halt besser netzwerken als
frauen und so weiter sondern ein
strukturproblem und strukturproblem
heißt letztlich ein gesellschaftliches
ein gesamtgesellschaftliches problem ich
bin selber vater eines fünfjährigen
sohns und ich weiß ganz genau meine frau
ist selber auch sehr stark aktives auch
die fortsetzung unserer stiftung hat
ganz andere herausforderungen und muss
sich bei jeder einzelnen diskussion mit
der frage konfrontieren lassen wo sie
eigentlich mit dem kind und ich sehe
dass auch frauen werden anders behandelt
ich habe sie ich habe schon vorher
erzählt ich hab sie google das erst was
kommt ist mit dem sie liiert waren
irgendwann also es sind frauen in der
politik wenn das handy nicht zu nahe
treten aber ich meine nur google ist und
du siehst allein schon bei algorithmus
zeit das zeigte ja etwas und das ist ja
nicht etwas natur gemacht das ist nicht
so dass unseren biologie uns darauf
trimmt sondern es ist eine gewisse und
gesellschaftliche trichter herr mal
jemand nicht nur einmal den wind in den
flügel rasen und zwar bei bei mir wird
auch bei google steht immer man oder
verheiratet kinder oder so sind auch bei
mir die ersten buga anfang das ist aber
auch bei männern so weil auch immer die
ich manchmal jemand google steht da auch
frau kim verheiratet ich glaube das hat
auch was emotionen des menschen vor
allem daran interessiert sind dass man
mich gemacht als männer nein das ist ja
auch dass sie auch eine gute sache aber
ich glaube im beten wir reden da von
politik und politik heißt dort wird das
volk abgebildet das heißt unsere
repräsentanten in österreich sind 183
abgeordneten die entscheiden was
übrigens gesetz gewährt ist und was
nicht das entscheidet auch darüber was
uns im land gemacht wird und das nicht
und ich glaube dass die politik bis zum
gewissen grade auch ein spiegelbild
unserer gesellschaft sein muss und wenn
wir jetzt erleben wie sie sagen das ist
in wirklichkeit keine kompatibilität von
einem menschenwürdigen leben und einer
politischen karriere so zugespitzt habe
ich das nicht gesagt und hilfreich ja es
kommt ja da habe ich aber nicht gesagt
und ich möchte im übrigen auch bestimmte
absolut beipflichten wenn sie das anders
sehen ich betone das jetzt noch mal es
gibt diese unterschiede und es gibt
diese schwierigkeiten punkt als
mittelschule zwischen man und trommeln
sind ja und vor allem wenn man dafür
wenn man hier im politischen kontext uns
bewegen und davon
es gibt endlich ja natürlich haben wir
aber jetzt aber in schuldig sie die
unterschiede auf politischer ebene sind
doch wohl hoffentlich nicht
biologistisch erzeugt er da hoffen sie
leider fehlt also das ist er tatsächlich
schon so ich kann das bestätigen es ist
frauen arbeiten anders frauen sind in
der politik in einem absoluten ellbogen
geschäft das ich erlebt da jeden tag
sehen wir das was wir über angela merkel
gesehen wie gut für eine frau an der
spitze des staates meine frau ja du hast
nicht über eine frau wir reden gerade
über frauen in der breite in der
gesellschaft und in der politik das hat
nichts mit angela merkel zu tun ja sie
gehört dazu gehört dazu aber dies bei
weitem nicht das paradebeispiel wie es
damit identifizieren würden und sagen
der allergrößte teil der frauen kann
sich jetzt damit würde jetzt sagen dass
sie mit den gemeinsamkeiten hat und sich
damit irgendwie identifizieren
bevor ich meine kinder bekommen habe
habe ich immer geglaubt okay wenn du dem
kind eine rose eine bohrmaschine kaufst
dann buttermann maschinen nicht in der
maschine bauerin daraus ja aber wie ist
die realität man sieht schon bei
zweijährigen bei dreijährigen dass die
interessen komplett unternehmen und da
tu ich gar nichts gebe ich dir
vollkommen recht so und darauf licher
hinaus und das ist eben die die
interessen sind von beginn an sehr sehr
unterschieden klar und auch im sozialen
verhalten sehr unterschiedlich jungs
machen so mädchen machen so kommt ein
junges mädchen aber hier geht es um
politik inklusive täglicher nicht
baugewerbe oder stricken
politik heißt doch vertreten wenn da
nicht das dann haben wir ein problem
politischen system und ich glaube dass
wir gerade das thema politik muss heißen
dass die repräsentantinnen und
repräsentanten der bürgerinnen und
bürger drinnen sitzen nicht nur die
nachricht auf irgendwelchen
politikerinnen und polizist zugerichtet
dass ihr enis traurig sein sollte wir
waren ja beim status quo ich dachte wir
reden darüber wie es sein sollte und
knackige ich muss mich also nicht
zusammenbringt einmal zu sagen was
gerade ist und einmal das ideal war ich
viel zu sagen wie es sein soll wir sehen
aber auch und das ist dann auch wieder
bemerkenswert die grünen haben sich ja
sehr schnell festgelegt bei der frage
wer wird eigentlich als nachfolger von
anne spiegel soll eine frau werden und
sie soll aus dem linken lager kommen und
wir warten seit 48 stunden oder weniger
gebannte also das land kann auch glaube
ich ohne familienministerin auskommen
wie wir sehen aber wir warten trotzdem
jahr 48 stunden gebannt wer glaubt denn
nun und offenbar ist das auch mal wieder
gar nicht so einfach hat man also sich
schnell wieder zu stark festgelegt auch
eine frage wie beide also muss es jetzt
frauen links sein oder das essen besser
wo wir sehen wohin quotierungen führen
da war wenn eine kurze unterbrechung
gehen dennoch an sachen frage frauchen
geweckt könnte es denn jetzt werden ob
sie vielleicht noch ein tipp für den
zuschauer wer vielleicht nächster
premierminister von ministerin wird oder
wer es sein sollte wenn gut würfeln ich
habe keine ahnung wenn ich ehrlich bin
also ich bin ja auch nicht zu nahe da
ich bin auch nicht so wirklich nah dran
bei den grünen wie die da ihre
entscheidungen treffen ein paar frauen
gibt es ja tatsächlich noch in der
fraktion paar männer gibt es auch man
könnte in der tat die qualität des amtes
vielleicht auch eben wenn man wenn man
einfach sich da nicht so einschränkt ja
aber das sollen sie entscheiden keine
weiß ich nicht sehr gut aber es war ein
gutes schlusswort zu der these ob mann
oder frau hauptsache kompetent für das
hand des familie ministers und wir sind
nach einer ganz kurzen unterbrechung
zurück mit zwei sehr spannend teams
gleich
also da kann ich einen lauten und nicht
ernst nehmen als sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 14 85 köpfen sind meinungen
von jeder von uns hat ein thema
mitgebracht was ihn bewegt freut oder
schockiert
so nicht rüber chipworks wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen hier einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der darin führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und kommen die füße russland die ratten
das thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur
der afg zu überlassen lasst den leuten
noch mal einen spaß wir sehen da etwas
was eigentlich fatale ist in der politik
bei den journalisten deren job ist es
doch gerade abweichende meinungen zu
fügen und sie sollen dem doch auch
richtig dürfte sein dass das gehirn
eines conti zum manko einmal kurz
doch das ist übliche an dem radträger
ausgesprochen wie das trinken ich hab
mein beifahrer meine sache immer bekommt
er kümmert sich darum niemand ist wahr
werden man ist ja ganz klar auch darüber
sprechen dass ein sagt nicht fährt und
ich richtig wo ist die ausgabe von
journalismus einfach die verlautbarungen
der politik zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und machen direkt weiter
mit dem thema was caroline post
beschäftigt vielen dank meine these
heute wir müssen uns als gesellschaft
neu aufstellen und dringend id
lebenslügen über bord werfen für die wir
jetzt gerade die quittung bekommen wir
müssen den realitäten ins auge blicken
und endlich lernen zu priorisieren was
meine ich damit zum beispiel die falsche
überzeugung dass wir nicht mehr
gefährdet sind er das ist ja immer noch
ein paar jahre lang ein weit
verbreiteter glaube der dazu geführt
hatte der situation wie wir sie jetzt
den vorgefunden haben natürlich brauchen
wir frieden mit russland wir brauchen
aber auch schutz vor russland an diesen
können wir nur bekommen wenn wir endlich
einsehen dass wir unsere bundeswehr auch
stärken und modernisieren müssen und
dass wir sie auch befähigen somit drei
das tun zu können was zur erfüllung
ihrer aufgaben notwendig ist so in
diesem zusammenhang müssen wir uns auch
fragen wie wir uns so abhängig machen
konnten vor einem energieträger gas also
ein weiterer weit verbreiteter
glaubenssatz von dem wir meiner meinung
nach rückzug zurück müssen denn ja die
behauptungen dass es keine einheimischen
energieträger braucht bis auf sonne und
wind ist ja absolut falsch richtig ist
dass natürlich die erneuerbaren energien
weiterhin an bedeutung gewinnen werden
aber ohne grundlastfähige energien
werden wir unser versprechen sicher
sauber und bezahlbar niemals halten
können drittens wir müssen zu guter
letzt auch mal loswerden der in diesen
irrglauben dass sämtliche
identitätsdebatte die debatten der
stunde sind und sein müssen ich kann nur
sagen ich akzeptiere alle wirklich alle
lebensentwürfe und entscheidungen des
individuums aber die erhöht die
überhöhung die klare überhöhung dieser
themen bringt uns nicht weiter ganz im
gegenteil
identitätsfragen sender und andere
angeblich mega wichtige themen die
versperren den blick nun leider auf das
was meiner meinung nach für die zukunft
unseres landes wirklich von großer
bedeutung ist das sind frieden freiheit
demokratie solide staatsfinanzen für
einen finanzierbaren sozialstaat und
sichere arbeitsplätze
spannend ja also ich weiß nicht welche
lebenslügen die deutschen sich der
einreden seit jahren tag ich glaube
nicht dass die deutschen entschieden
haben mit putin geschäfte zu machen um
billiges gas zu bekommen das schon ihre
politischen entscheidungsträgerinnen und
entscheidungsträger
ich glaube auch dass ganz viele menschen
in den letzten jahrzehnten gute mit
gewirtschaftet haben gewisse
entscheidungen zu treffen also ich
glaube die lebenslügen ich finde es gut
und eine politikerin sagt sie muss sich
von ihren lebenslügen befreien das finde
ich gut ich finde auch gut dass die cdu
vielleicht beginnt einmal einen diskurs
zu gehen mit welchen lebenslügen oder
mit welchen politischen lügens league
beschäftigen möchte aber ich würde schon
empfehlen ein bisschen zu differenzieren
zwischen den bürgerinnen und bürgern in
dem land in europa in österreich in
deutschland ist er vollkommen irrelevant
und dem was jetzt die politische kaste
unter anführungszeichen und die
entscheidungsträgerinnen den letzten
jahren verbrochen haben ich sehe auch
ehrlich gesagt ich weiß das in
deutschland genau so ein großes thema
wie in österreich diese länder debatten
und so weiter über die unglaublich viele
berichtet wirklich unglaublich
aufgeblasen werden wo ich aber den
großen konflikt nicht sehr ehrlich
gesagt ja ich sehe dass die menschen
ihre lebensentwürfe haben und ich sehe
jetzt nicht den grund warum die große
portieren müssen dass man schön oder
nicht schön
wäre natürlich ständig und zwar deswegen
weil sprache wirklichkeit schaue nicht
sender nicht weil darin ein
antifeministen allein schon die debatte
empfehlen schauen sie ich glaube als
privatperson können sie entscheiden wie
sie ihre text formulieren traktoren ja
großartig und können sie das mit ihrem
verlage ausmachen oder auch nicht aber
ich persönlich finde aber hier gehen die
debatte warum debattiert werden aber
dass die debatte haben wir jetzt nur
deswegen weil sie mich darauf ansprechen
dass man darüber reden was wirklich
wichtig ist nämlich die 161 1000 armen
kinder in berlin über die reden lesen
dass anke werden über das spinnentier
und die reden über kämpfen sie doch
scheint das thema habe ich mitgebracht
gebracht weil sie haben damit klar ist
dasselbe thema das das gleiche team und
ich finde es so wichtig ich möchte sich
das über mein team reden sondern über
das thema das die post aufgesprochen
angesprochen hat und das ist das thema
lebenslügen und ich finde lebenslüge und
politische lügen bedeutet dass wir
scheindebatten führen und ich glaube das
ist eine scheindebatte ich glaube das
ist nicht das was den menschen unter den
nägeln brennt unter den menschen bringt
mich unter den nägeln ob sie jetzt
ändern oder ist schon als vollkommen
irrelevant relevante
meinung nicht die öffnung der ehe da bin
ich aber eben nicht hundertprozentig war
ihr mann bekommt oftmals ein wieso wir
uns noch gar nicht wie sophie schütt und
sie hat so den kopf es ist doch der
punkt ist doch dass folgender dass das
was uns oftmals er medial präsentiert
wird gar nicht das ist womit sich die
menschen beschäftigen die haben ganz
andere sorgen zum beispiel so was wie
habe ich am ende des monats noch genug
geld auf dem konto sagt ist doch genau
warum sollten wir das tun wir gerade
hier aber dann sollte man nicht über
identität cent für versprechen am ende
des tages
können ja bezahlen
naja also also weiß ich was ich
tatsächlich im politischen alltag
erleben dass wir eine lebenswirklichkeit
draußen und der bevölkerung haben und
wir haben eine politische
lebenswirklichkeit und diese politische
lebenswirklichkeit geht hand in hand mit
der veröffentlichten meinung und ich
versuche wirklich dafür zu werben nah
bei den menschen zu sein auch mal auf
volkes mund zu schauen ja und danach
entscheidungen zu treffen und insofern
ich würde mir wünschen dass wir politik
machen mit gesundem menschenverstand die
genau das abbildet ja uns nicht treiben
lassen uns nicht hysterisch machen
lassen keine verschlüsselten
identitätsdebatte nerz führen und und
und und geschlechtsneutrale toiletten
und was weiß ich was es da noch so alles
gibt sondern einfach versuchen die
probleme zu lösen die wir tatsächlich
haben und vor allen dingen uns nicht den
mund verbieten sie beim namen nennen ja
mal die dinge auf den punkt bringen ja
und sie mal aussprechen schon daran
scheitert ist ja in diesem land überwog
dinge berichten wir bei bild ja auch auf
der identitätspolitik jan als
ressortleiter politik wirtschaft müssen
wir da auch kritisch mit uns selbst sein
als größte tageszeitung wir berichten
über die themen aber wenn man bei uns
auf die onlineseite geht wenn man tv
schaut oder auch in die zeitung dann
wird man feststellen dass das themen
sind die wir auch behandeln aber dass es
viele viele andere themen gibt über die
wir zum teil oder in der regel auch noch
viel viel stärker
berichten und natürlich sie sprechen
themen an wie das thema armut oder das
thema verteilung das thema energie wurde
angesprochen hat eine der lebenslügen
und frau schimpft gesagt zu recht wir
müssen gucken dass wir uns mit den
sorgen und nöten der menschen
beschäftigen und ich glaube weil du das
jetzt gerade anspruchs ist es genau das
bild genau das richtige medium beim
thema energie die große lebenslüge aus
der kernkraft auszusteigen jetzt wie ein
wilder durch die welt zu fahren und ohne
zu kaufen und gas zu kaufen anstatt zu
sagen wir lassen die drei maler die wir
haben länger laufen und die 3d
abgeschaltet haben bringen wir auch noch
ans netzt wäre relativ einfach möglich
wird aber nicht gemacht bei der frage
weil sie immer wieder auf dieses thema
kommen kinderarmut und finde ich toll
dass sie das ja auch reinbringen dieses
mal vielleicht dann auch als die these
ist mir der ansatz den sie machen aber
zum beispiel das ist dann glaube ich
auch eine lebenslüge zu sagen wir
verteilen einfach das geld um und dann
geht es den kindern gut wir müssen dann
mal schauen warum gibt es denn dann so
viele arme kinder was ist da eigentlich
los navarro hat hat es möglicherweise
was mit dem thema bildung zu tun könnt
ja auch ist selber schuld den habe ich
jetzt aber müssen sie müssen dann wir
uns zuhören und nicht nur erstellen und
wenn sie hierfür geradezu gehörten habe
ich gesagt hat es möglicherweise was mit
dem thema bildung zu tun das ist ja ein
großes thema quasi wie es in österreich
ist in deutschland eine riesen thema
wenn man sich schulabschlüsse am guckt
von heute schulabschlüsse vergleich von
vor 20 jahren beispielsweise wären sie
sehen dass das bildungsniveau nicht
gerade besser geworden ist es mit
kinderarmut zu tun können - kurz
erklären kann ich die kritik sehr gut
erklären bei menschen die beispielsweise
keinen job haben und arm sind auf hartz
iv angewiesen sind möglicherweise kinder
haben die dann schon in armut groß
werden das hat was mit bildung zu tun
das hat was mit fortbildung zu tun das
hat auch was damit zu tun ob kinder
nicht selbst schaffen sie tun so
besonders schlau und so überlegen aber
den gedanken darf ich noch mal zu ende
bringen vielleicht weil er gar nicht von
mir stammt sondern von vielen schlauen
bildungsforschern dass auch kinder die
dann einen schulabschluss haben der aber
vielleicht gar nicht so viel wert ist
weil sie gar nicht so viel gelernt haben
wie man das eigentlich könnte in juni an
auch weniger chancen auf dem
arbeitsmarkt haben und das ist ja das
also sind die armen doch selber schon
habe ich aber dass ich gesagt habe was
jetzt gerade gesagt haben sie müssten
über die armut von kindern sprechen über
die bildung sprechen aber mit wohnt in
welchen sie sagt welchem satz nein
schulden sie mal das ist echt eine
wirklich perfide unterstellung die sie
machen na das ist ja mal ein schlechtes
bildungssystem dafür kann doch der hartz
4 empfänger nichts dafür kann das kind
auch nichts dafür kann wenn überhaupt
warum reden wir über bildung wenn wir
über kinderarmut spreche das haben sie
gemacht wenn wir über arm und gemüse
sind wieder viele müssen wir etwas tun
die ihnen genau sagen dass man ihm aber
waren aber was macht man da was ist mit
menschen was sie gerade gewachsen
mitmenschen region zwischen bildungen
guten jobs dass das muss ich sagen was
was es aber natürlich viel besser ich
ausgebildet bin ja in der regel um so
eine barriere umso besser kann ist mein
job und wenn wir sehen das ist viel am
hut nicht mehr tut wir sehen dass es
viele hartz vier familien gibt
beispielsweise dann ist doch immer die
frage warum beziehen menschen hartz4 ja
wir sind ausgebildet sind wie gut
qualifiziert sind die nicht gut
qualifiziert und warum leben menschen in
hartz iv und mir zu sagen weil ich über
das thema bildung rede seine bodenlose
unterstellung zu sagen ich hätte den
sozusagen gesagt sie haben selbst schuld
ist das gegenteil ist der fall das
gegenteil ist der fall der staat hat
beim thema bildung die aufgabe dafür zu
sorgen dass gerade diejenigen die aus
vielleicht für haushalten kommen denen
es sozial nicht so gut geht dafür zu
sorgen dass diese kinder ein abschluss
bekommen mit dem sie einen richtig guten
job kriegen aber das ist ja die
lebenslüge die ihr das schon wieder
dieselbe lebenslüge also entschuldigen
sie gerade wo es angesprochen die
lebenslüge zu sagen mit einer guten
ausbildung bekommt man einen guten job
und einen guten job kann man sich seine
miete leisten das ist eine lüge er stand
einfach
unter der canarios krankenpflege
deutschland noch die miete in berlin
leisten ich weiß nicht vielleicht weiß
nicht wie ein studium besuchen grund
von januar
an noch die mieten leisten ist noch ein
anderes problem ist doch gerade noch ein
ganz anderes problem sie verstanden
nicht schön nerven hier wird für den
eindruck ausbildung geholfen wir möchten
natürlich auch noch die these heute von
jan schäfer hören wie enten aktuell
heute in der sendung und zwar mit der
regenbogenfahne von nancy faeser ja das
ist richtig aber ich werde auch über das
thema mieten noch weiter gibt gerne
deine redezeit irgendeiner seite haben
heute in deutschland genau eine eine
mitteilung der
bundesinnenministerium vernommen es geht
um das thema regenbogenflagge eine frage
die ich großartig finde weil ich zum
einen die farben wunderbar finde und
weil ich das ganze was hinter dieser
flagge auch steckt für sehr sehr
bewundernswert halten und eine große
leistung die frage die sich aber
aufdrängt ist jetzt und das ist das was
nancy faeser heute beschlossen hat
muss diese flagge auch vor öffentlichen
gebäuden hängen sollte sie vor
öffentlichen gebäuden hängen darf sie
vor öffentlichen gebäuden hängen und da
habe ich sagen in diesem staat nein es
gibt ein neutralitätsgebot des staates
und es gibt ein recht zu sagen wir
stellen vor öffentlichen gebäuden
hoheitliche flaggen auf also
beispielsweise schwarz-rot-gold schwarze
gold im übrigen eine flagge die für
freiheit steht die für offenheit steht
die für toleranz steht und die auch für
ein modernes deutschland steht unter dem
sich so wie ich der meinung alle
menschen hier im land versammeln können
ich gebe ihnen herr schäfer absolut
recht wir haben klare regeln in
deutschland welche flaggen sich vor
welchen gebäuden befinden dürfen und wir
haben die hoheitlichen flaggen wenn wir
ausländische gäste empfangen dann kommt
auch noch die flagge des fonds des
landes noch hinzu ja oder die flagge des
bundeslandes ja und natürlich auch der
bundesrepublik deutschland und der
europäischen union das ist das was für
unseren behörden hängt wenn wir jetzt
die regenbogenflagge auch noch aufhängen
dann stelle ich die frage wo soll das
denn ändern welchen flaggen wollen wir
den späteren noch in hängt dann kommt
wieder eine bewegung und noch ein trend
und noch irgendein thema ja und dann
befinden wir uns auch wieder in einer
politischen debatte die irgendwo kein
ende findet ich möchte erinnern an die
situation die wir ich glaube es ist
ungefähr ein jahr her wo viele
unternehmen in der deutschen wirtschaft
sich dazu entschieden haben auch diese
platten vor ihrem betriebsgelände
aufzustellen das hat zu heftigsten
diskussionen geführt in der gesellschaft
man hat sich mal wieder in eine ecke
gedrängt gefühlt man hat sich mal wieder
einer meinung aufgedrückt gesehen und
das hat so und ruin geführt und in der
tat ich glaube wir sollten uns hier auf
das nötigste beschränken auf das was
wirklich auch die bundesrepublik
präsentiert und nicht die
regenbogenfahne wissen auch um gar nicht
missverstanden zu werden jeder kann
diese regenbogen flagge hissen wenn er
möchte ist doch ein wunderbares zeichen
kann sie aus einem fenster hängen kann
sie vor seinem garten aufstellen auf dem
balkon wie auch mal dagegen ist
überhaupt nichts zusammen ist seine
freie entscheidung seine tolle flagge
soll jeder machen die frage ist immer
nur neutralitätsgebot des staates
und da glaube ich ist es gut wenn man
sich da auf das beschränkt was wir
bisher haben hoheitszeichen aber sie
sind natürlich andere meinung doch klar
holt einmal ladies first ein anderer
bachrain weil ich glaube sonst wird uns
hier wieder zu schnell wenn sie nicht
genug zu wort kommen frau berichtet ihr
etwas wendezeit verwöhnt das ist ganz
großartig diebe fasching im grunde das
ist meine ganz persönliche meinung jetzt
hätte ich bei speziellen bei ganz
besonderen veranstaltung und
beispielsweise ganz konkret csd
freitag wieder in berlin kein problem
damit keine bauchschmerzen hat ganz
grundsätzlich sehe ich jetzt aber sehr
ähnlich dass wir schon eine wunderbare
flagge haben und sie steht für unsere
demokratie alles was damit zu tun nicht
und wir sagen mit dieser frage drücken
mit ihr aus dass wir niemanden
ausgrenzen weder aufgrund seiner
religion auch aufgrund seines
geschlechts was auch immer das heißt ich
steht für toleranz steht für offenheit
steht für freiheit und somit auch für
frieden vor allem auch für ein
friedliches zusammenleben
die flagge steht für toleranz und
dementsprechend das ist ja dein
impliziert sie schon das ist also wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe dann
geht es nicht darum dass die flaggen
gehisst werden müssen sondern dass die
gefühle fragen gehisst werden dürfen ich
verstehe überhaupt nicht die debatte
ehrlich gesagt dass ich mir zum jahr
1960 dass man darüber debattieren ob vor
einem amtsgebäude in regenbogenflagge
gehisst werden darf oder nicht ernst das
ist den wir hier in deutschland das
sieht man in österreich schon viel
weiter und wissen wie man die
hinterwäldler also in österreich haben
wir in amtsgebäuden auch wenn der
amtsträger oder die amtsträgerin
entscheidet sie möchten ein zeichen
setzen zu einer parade oder einfach
aufgrund eines gedenktages oder einfache
weise ein zeichen setzen möchte dann tut
sie das das jetzt überhaupt zu
debattieren also dass wir jetzt
überhaupt noch darüber reden müssen ob
das ob wir jetzt quasi in eine ecke
gedrängt werden oder ob deswegen die
deutsche fahne abgewertet wird oder
relativiert wird und so weiter ganz
offensichtlich ist diese politikerin der
meinung dass es wichtig ist dass man
auch als staat im zeichen setzt und ich
finde das gut und richtig ich bin so
aber nicht homosexuell aber ich finde es
gut und wichtig dass das auch mal
gezeigt wird das als start und diese
dieser beißreflex dass man ich bin ich
wieder verstehen wenn es irgendwie ein
ass im bundestag beschlossen wird es
müssen alle regenbogenfahne gehisst
werden kann man darüber debattieren
würden wir wahrscheinlich auch zu weit
gehen aber ganz ehrlich da wurde gesagt
sie möchte dass es mit ich sein kann was
für ängste haben sie bitte in sich dass
sie angst davor habe dass irgendjemand
in deutschland jeden tag ein zeichen
indem wir nach recht und gesetz leben
indem wir unser grundgesetz haben das
ist das was uns lenkt und leitet und
finde damit ist dem thema auch genüge
getan aber sie haben dass er glaube ich
richtig gesagt und das beantwortet ein
bisschen ihre frage
die frage ist ja wie geht es dann weiter
und das ist immer so ein punkt glaube
ich über den mann sprechen muss wir
haben es hier mit einem einem sehr
starken symbol für toleranz und freiheit
zu tun aber es könnten vielleicht auch
gesellschaftliche gruppen auf die idee
kommen da andere flaggen hissen zu
wollen und dann kommen wir auch sehr
schnell als gesellschaft immer in diese
frage ja wem erlauben wir jetzt
eigentlich noch was das ist ja genau die
debatte und deswegen es ist glaube ich
gut wenn ein staat ein neutralitätsgebot
habe es gab in berlin in den vergangenen
jahren als zum csd beispielsweise auch
schon vor behörden gehisst wurde
polizisten die sich weigerten das zu tun
so und dann wurde ihnen mit
disziplinarverfahren gedroht weil die
polizisten sich auf das
neutralitätsgebot des staates und das
ist hier sehr gutes recht berufen haben
die sind ja auch im einsatz die müssen
dann ja auch dokumentieren und auch
sagen ich stehe jetzt für den neutralen
staat so da wird es ja sehr
problematisch und das glaube ich muss
man sehr ernst nehmen und deswegen hat
der staat in deutschland glaube ich
bisher gute erfahrungen damit gemacht zu
sagen wie ich ja wir verhalten uns in
gewisser weise sehr sehr neutral aber
schaut kann sich auch weiterentwickeln
würde und ich glaube wenn wir im jahr
2002 an und sie denn äußerlich die
deutsche fahne schon toleranz impliziert
nein wenn ich mir anschaue was sind
neubauten alles alltag ist was nicht von
toleranz geprägt dies so wie ich glaube
wir haben vor kurzem gestern oder
vorgestern eine riesen aktion gegen
rechtsextremismus in deutschland gehabt
dann muss ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen nein
ich glaube nicht dass das alles implizit
ist und vor allem dürfen mit den fehler
nicht machen dass wir von unserer andere
schwer zu glauben dass wenn sie jetzt
die fahne anschauen und deswegen
freiheit und so weiter damit implizieren
das ist schön dass du diese gefühle
haben wenn sie die fahne an schon
großartig aber ich glaube so ganz viele
menschen fühlen sich diskriminiert
aufgrund von blau de minimis auf haben
hatte selber sichtbare migranten ich hab
selber rassismus erfahrungen gemacht das
heißt nicht dass ich mir jetzt wünsche
irgendwelche antirassismus flaggen
gehisst werden aber ich kann gut
nachvollziehen dass menschen die
vielleicht nicht aus privilegiertem haus
kommen die vielleicht nicht von klein
auf gelernt haben dass sie zur gruppe
der stärkeren gehören sich auch mal
wünschen dass der staat ein zeichen
setzt und mein gott was ist das problem
ja gerade endlich willst du gar land
wenn ich muss leider sehr sie der
ambrosia aber es ist schon viel leid
dass er zu schnell passiert aber bis
morgen abend 20 15
[Musik]